familiar carana nice short game here
take us through every single move of the
queen end game if you could where you
thought you had an advantage and where
you thought it was a draw
i i can't tell if you're joking or not i
am joking
but tell us a little bit about the
opening novelty we actually love this uh
how did you come up with this move roxy
one we saw a lot of uh
correspondence games we know that you
use those very often for your
preparation when how did you come up
with this move
well i i um realized something which is
that
i mean even though i play pretty awfully
recently
i do destroy one opening which is the
night or all my wins are in this one
opening yes maybe maybe you shouldn't
tell that to your opponent you have a
lot of them coming up well maxime is uh
is one of the few night of players
remaining
so um
yeah roxy one was an idea uh from from
the candidate's preparation
i expected him to know what to do but
even if you know it you know you you
might not remember all the details and
it remains very very difficult
he played
the first move correctly and then after
queen e4
uh
well rookie five is the most natural
move but rookie is the best move right
it is a four straw
but it's a very very complicated four
straw
and
so yeah he couldn't remember and he came
up with his rookie five f6 which looks
terrible
but i couldn't find the reputation and
also is terrible i mean okay now i see
queen d4 but it's not the queen e4 is
not even a move i considered like
if you let it run a little bit longer it
does think queen d2 is even stronger but
queen d2 fg i didn't see the way here
fg in this position we just take
yeah but take queen d6 isn't this bishop
c1 bishop d3m bishop c1 bishop d3
because it's made on f8 at the end for
some reason i thought
that with the rook on e5 this would hold
for black but with the rook on c it
doesn't matter rook on c5 or e5 like i
was trying to get this with the rook on
c5
and uh with the rook over here yeah
yeah because i thought like
i thought bishop h6 queen e5 bc
like i this is the line i was looking at
and i thought i need my queen on c5 so i
have bishop c4 check mm-hmm and okay now
i see queen d5 queen e4
um
well like this this idea of queen e4 and
with the pin didn't like enter my mind
um this is like why i why i um rejected
it
and i thought queen h2 was strong but
after rook c5
you have to go back basically yeah i can
play queenie to rookie five queen d2 but
i still didn't see this
i was kind of convinced that i need this
position with the rook on c5 that's why
i played queen d2 immediately after
repeating once
and yeah kinghead was kind of what i
thought he should play
um
i thought i would have a big advantage
here but he was defending like
this whole rookie 5 d5 was a remarkably
good idea yeah especially considering
that after f4 he still can take the
bishop
what's up considering that after f4 he
can still take on c4 yeah
yeah i i thought that it would be a very
bad end game after dc but like i didn't
have another option because d5 bishop a6
queen f4 and he
like it just turns into a mess if i take
on a6 instead of f4 ah okay yes like
it's kind of the first within queen f4
and like it's a big mess his king is no
longer in danger yeah i can play this
bishop b5 i was thinking about it but my
pawns are moving slowly and
i don't know like i didn't think i would
be able to keep control of this
situation
and then eventually you got to this
queen end game and we are not going to
talk about it
okay so generally with like the two
pawns up it's
there's a lot of positions which are
drawn yes and a lot of positions which
are winning and they all kind of look
the same yes but after g6 i just didn't
see what else to do no you you were
playing perfectly until very late
winning but i just didn't like find the
way to do it we just kept the tally
italia was two to two
sometimes you gave up the win and two
times he gave up the draw but which is
not too bad considering the complexity
of the end game well once my king had it
was forced back then it's a draw yes yes
but i mean this i figured but i i had no
choice because um
otherwise he just like has a perpetual
right but i i
yeah i assume that like at some point i
play a5 a6 in this configuration but i
just couldn't find the moment to do it
and i was kind of trying to like play
some moves to gain time on the clock and
wait around a bit which is i guess why i
also missed um the win yeah really the
only confusing moment everything else is
very explicable but the only confusing
moment was move 64 i think
uh very very specifically where we
thought you played perfectly until that
moment like every single decision was
absolutely spot on but before b5 here we
assumed what must have been very
attractive and we thought this was sort
of yeah b5 was my first intention and
then after like king c king b7 i
couldn't like
find i don't know and i was worried that
i'm you know pushing the beep on is is
not the right way normally you push the
a pawn but
but i i just didn't see the win here so
and i thought okay he's going to play
king b7 immediately and i have to find a
win with two minutes
and now my king is a bit more open so
that's why i didn't go for this
and and i had this idea that okay maybe
i should be kind of patient
and wait around a bit longer
um
but yeah i guess it's winning somehow
here
fabia a big victory for you for the
standings not only of the tournament but
the grand chess tour in general how are
you feeling after this marathon game
no i mean this was great this was
exactly what i needed after yesterday um
playing two very difficult games in a
row so i am quite tired as well i know
that it was already a while ago but you
must have noticed that sort of magnus
carlson missing in the playing hall
today uh your thoughts
well
um
i mean i guess there's a lot of rumors
already
and i assume he hasn't given the reason
yet why he decided not to play
but uh probably some people have a
decent idea of what he's alluding to
uh or what he has a problem with i don't
know but i i'm not going to
to say anything else about it sounds
good well fabio was a long day so we
want you to get out of here so we can
get out of here congratulations on your
win thank you
indeed a very very